they work like detectives trying to
trace a silent
killer ebola health workers questioned
the son of a nurse who died from the
virus in early february
asking questions on what she ate where
she went
and what she did did he see anything
unusual
before her death still in shock he calls
out to his deceased mother
mom i can't stop crying people say you
died of ebola
but we don't really know is this true
are they lying to us
god only knows i feel powerless night
and day i cry
why did you have to go he is not alone
in doubting ebola's resurgence
at the epicenter of the outbreak the
regional market is bustling despite a
ban on public gatherings
worse meat from wild animals known to
harbor ebola
is sold in stalls
what you are seeing here is not a big
deal people are just informed some
haven't come to the market
but those people you see here are
foreigners from neighboring countries
in 2015 more than 11 000 people died and
20 000
were infected after the virus spread
from guinea's forest region
to neighboring liberia and sierra leone
the outbreak was contained
after an experimental vaccine was
distributed but not before health
workers were attacked by people who did
not believe in the virus
infected patients were kept in isolation
and the dead were taken away
buried without their families being
present
a good lesson we learned is that instead
of doing everything by ourselves we
have to give the resources and the means
to the population and to the localized
workers
the local authorities to manage that
break by themselves
we cannot continue coming with big wild
suv and with a lot of people in small
villages
eleven thousand vaccines and two hundred
health workers have just arrived in
guinea's capital konakui to help manage
this latest outbreak the doses will go
to front-line health workers
and close contacts patients are being
treated in
nzerikore konakri and little by the
malian border
almost a month after lua's mother died
of ebola
the virus is spreading nicholas hawk al
jazeera